Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate it.
You guys are here.
You guys are --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, we are coming to you
after the first NFL game
of the season,
between the Dallas Cowboys
and the Tampa Bay buccaneers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Buccaneers
are trying to win their
second straight Super Bowl
and Tom Brady's eighth.
-Ooh!
-After that, Brady will have to
make a bold choice
whether or not
to become a thumb-ring guy.
Yep, Brady is the
defending champ at age 44,
and he's actually older than
13 of the coaches in the NFL.
When they tell him to do
something he's like,
"Don't use that tone
with me, young man."
That's right -- at 44 years old,
Brady is starting his
22nd season.
At this point, the only thing
in the NFL older than Brady
is Bill Belichick's sweatshirt.
Jesus.
Did you see that thing?
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
That's been through a couple --
-Come on!
-That's waxed a few cars,
I think.
Yeah, look at that.
But it was a big match-up,
Dallas and Tampa Bay.
Texas versus Florida.
Fans from both teams were
looking at each other like,
"Thank God we don't live
there right now."
Yeah, the Bucs
are a Super Bowl favorite,
but, on the flip side,
the Houston Texans only have
a 0.4% chance of winning it all.
The Texans said if
they lose the first few games,
they're just going to
turn the stadium
into a pop-up Halloween store.
Oh, and people were
talking about this.
Ed Sheeran performed at
the kickoff concert
before tonight's game.
But the photo the NFL used to
promote it was a little strange.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
I couldn't tell if
they were promoting the game
or a reboot of
"Two and a Half Men."
Yeah, guys, football is back.
But there's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's actually just
one tiny thing
that's been on my mind
about the NFL,
so I decided to
write a song about it.
Now, if you don't mind, Roots,
can I get a beat?
♪♪
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
So, what's up with Raiders owner
Mark Davis' haircut?
Bro!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate that. Thank you.
Had to get it off my chest.
Thank you, Roots.
Some business news.
Today, Burger King
made a big announcement
that they're removing
120 artificial ingredients
from their food.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Now the Whopper is officially
just a pickle slice.
-Oh.
-That's the Whopper.
That's the Whopper.
-That's the whole Whopper.
-Well, this is pretty cool.
I read that Tesla
just got a patent on
laser windshield wipers
that can zap debris off cars.
Yeah, the laser works
like a charm,
unless you have a cat
riding shotgun.
"Get that!"
Some more business news.
I read that UPS
is hiring 100,000 workers
for the holiday season.
Working for UPS
should be an easy sell.
I mean, sure, you don't get
to see your family
during the holidays,
but at least you get to drive
in a doorless car in the winter.
You know what I'm saying?
And, finally, I heard about
an Australian man
who set a new world record by
planking for 9 1/2 hours.
-Ooh!
-He was actually following an
online fitness class,
and then the screen froze,
but he just kept going.
9 1/2 hours of planking.
At that point, you're not an
athlete -- you're a table.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ I'm up, I'm out ♪
♪ I'm moving all about ♪
♪ It's not you again ♪
♪ Oh, yes, no doubt ♪
♪ Yo, where's my joy,
she at P-A State ♪
♪ Sunshine, it's time to play ♪
♪ Play on, playa ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a show
we have for you tonight.
He stars in the new movie
"Vacation Friends."
It just had the biggest opening
for an original movie
in Hulu history.
John Cena is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
John Cena!
-Love him.
-Plus, he's got a brand-new
album out tonight, fresh,
called "Jose."
J Balvin is here!
-Oh!
-It's out right now.
We're going to talk to him,
and then he's performing
for us in studio!
It is a show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then, later in the show,
we have an all-new
"Tonight Show Hashtags,"
everybody.
So, yeah,
it's a big show tonight.
I'm very excited.
You guys, as I mentioned,
football is back,
and the first game of the season
was earlier tonight,
right here on on NBC --
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
versus the Dallas Cowboys.
And, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player.
But they also give out awards
at the start of the season.
-Oh.
-I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show Superlatives" ♪
-Our first player, from the
Bucs, is Rob Gronkowski.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was voted Most Likely to Yell
"Spring Break!" In September.
And, you know,
it's Spring Break somewhere.
Next up, from the Cowboys,
is Leighton Vander Esch.
He was voted Most Likely To Have
"Neck Day" At The Gym.
It's neck day, bro.
Can you spot my --
-Spot my neck.
-Next up, from the Bucs,
is Vita Vea.
He was voted Most Likely
To Say His Own Name
Like The Little Caesar's Guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Vita Vea.
-Next up, from the Cowboys,
is CeeDee Lamb.
He was voted Most Likely
To Prank Call
With The Fake Name
"Cee Deez Nuts."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, can I have
some pizza for..."
-Caller I.D.
-Next up, from the Bucs,
is Grant Stuard.
He was voted Most Likely To Do
A Touchdown Dance
To Kenny G.'s "Songbird."
[ Band plays
Kenny G's "Songbird" ]
♪♪
Next up, from the Cowboys,
is DeMarcus Lawrence.
He was voted Most Likely To Say
"You Better Watch Out, I'm
Wearing My Football Glasses."
[ Applause ]
Next up, from the Cowboys,
is Connor Williams.
He was voted Most Likely To
Reply, "I Didn't Eat
Any Gummies" To Any Question
You Ask Him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Bucs,
we have Leonard Fournette.
He was voted Most Likely
To Have A Magnetic Beard.
[ Laughter ]
Don't sneeze. Don't sneeze.
And, finally,
we have the quarterback
of the Bucs, Tom Brady.
He was voted Most Likely To Lose
A Super Bowl Ring And Say,
"Eh, I'll Get A New One."
There you go.
Those are your
"NFL Superlatives."